what is happening there reject nation
thank you guys so much for clicking on
this video
that's all i want to say thanks to the
boys of prepper for helping us
throughout 2021 and with the
highlights this year as well guys let's
just go into it you know where to find
us for the full-length watch alongs over
at patreon also if you go hit the like
button that would be great and you know
might as well subscribe and click that
notification bell to get notified when a
reaction the next episode is up
hey i still mentioned everything let's
do this
[Music]
oh no mabel i i don't feel so good
oh no uncle stan why did you feed us
taking me back guys guys stop something
terrible just happened
whose birthday is it again nobody's
thought this party might be a good way
to get kids to spend money at the shack
nice
[Music]
hey hey how's about you make yourself
useful and copy these flyers
free
you know the old copier in my office i
finally fixed the old girl up good as
new
butterflies
[Music]
oh no
success
[Applause]
they copy him it copied his arm it's a
3d printer oh my gosh mabel i think this
copier can copy human beings
that's cool
do you realize what this means
what a cool concept yeah has that has
that been done before
i don't know if it's been done with like
just a copy machine
that's cool yeah i like it
it's like yeah it's the appropriate
whimsical twilight zone
kind of setup reminds me a little bit of
the spongebob where he gets the magic
pencil but he draws the character and
then the character comes to life yeah
kind of different
zeus because you'll work for free and
you begged i'm letting you be dj i got
this book to teach me how to dj rara
right
you got to commit to staying at the
ticket stand with wendy no getting out
of it just the two of you alone
[Laughter]
i promise
bow ties are cool uh uh i can work the
counter with you wendy let's kiss
[Music]
hey i have devised a plan to make sure
my night with wendy goes perfect
oh you're not making one of those
over-complicated listy things are you
all right hold that there
okay
step one that's like my to-do list yeah
see this isn't banner this is what i
want to avoid with wendy the final step
is to ask her to dance more clean pants
i'm so happy you decided to work the
ticket stand with me you're so organized
keeps his hat on
why can't you just walk up and talk to
her like a normal person
step nine sister
perfect the energy it's electric uh
lightning lightning lightning
and if anyone wants to leave i'm
charging an exit fee of 15 bucks we've
only got 13. we're trapped
step one casual banter so here's a
casual question okay what's your
favorite type of snack food oh man i
can't just pick one no way mine too
wait
[Laughter]
new topic
[Music]
fly outfit mabel you've got an animal on
your body i'm mabel hi i'm granda this
is candy
why do you love forks taped to your
fingers
i found my people
[Laughter]
party crowd
most applause at the end of the night
wins i'll take that and thank you very
much the most popular girl in town
pacifica northwest who's gonna compete
against me for girl
lizard lady
get in there
our kind is welcome here
nah you gotta fix this mabel i'll
compete
i'm mabel that sounds like a fat old
lady's name i'll take that as a
compliment whoa sounds like the party's
getting nuts label comes out strong
watch out pacifica
i gotta get in there cover for me well i
thanks man oh yep
you can clone yourself
i forgot all about that
what are you doing kid these suckers
aren't gonna rip themselves off
yeah
good attention to the sign only i could
be two places at once you can
[Music]
you left your booth i wonder if this is
a good idea
yes it is
[Music]
whoa
i have a really big head
i'm sorry you first
stop copying me
[Laughter]
ah
i will call you
number two definitely not you know what
name i've always wanted
tyrone
you are a tyrone
while i ask wendy to dance i know the
plan buddy
there's tyrone is just a shade whiter
we're not gonna get jealous and turn on
each other like the clones in the movies
are we you can always just disintegrate
me with water
i don't want to copy myself i got
somebody to cover the concessions for me
that's awesome you can hang out with me
and robbie
robbie you remember dipper from the
convenience store yo wendy check out my
new guitar
[Music]
it's not even plugged in yeah it sounds
amazing
rod but kiss me anyway because you can
play guitar i forgot something
let's get married tonight
and sues can play saxophone on a trumpet
oh no they're sitting on the couch we
gotta think of something quick
i got an idea i got the same one but
we're gonna need some help
[Music]
that's where you come in number three
but what if robbie catches me i'll be
all alone
okay one more one more clone
oh golly uh oh paper jam
every ninth dipper has special abilities
like house of cosby's
[Music]
or that
come on you're not gonna make yes
hey buddy hey it's okay yeah oh golly it
is unsettling yes it is
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Laughter]
plastic oh grenda by the way you sound
like a professional wrestler
i want to put her in a headlock and make
her feel pain it's not over toad's over
sister i wonder if it's a guest star
rule yeah maybe give me the adhesive
crowd-pleasing it's rock valley song you
got
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
yeah mabel with the owner of a silver
and red dirt bike please report outside
it is being stolen right now wait what
oh no
[Music]
oh nice
[Music]
ask her
now's your chance to ask wendy to dance
get rejected the dance floor is a
minefield a minefield tyrone
[Laughter]
[Music]
my field tyro what could go wrong
are you all clear on what to do
jesus look a glowing dot
oh man i'm so glad i turned my head that
dot does not disappoint
right like i'm gonna fall for that
oh hey man what's up
what are you doing here i'm just waiting
for the bathroom so hey let's see
everyone at this party gets stuck on a
desert island who do you think the
leader would be hm
i think i'd go with this lunatic
[Music]
[Laughter]
stretch over there because tall people
can reach coconuts
[Music]
those are my three brothers and i'm
boop
huh you know kids used to make fun of my
birthmark before i started hiding it all
the time birthmark uh no it's nothing oh
now you have to show me show me show me
[Music]
the big dipper
that's how you got your nickname oh
i guess we're both freaks
ah
wait here of course
what are you doing up here number 10 has
been distracting zeus for 15 minutes
he's gonna get tired of that dot
eventually never
i bumped into wendy accidentally and
things are actually going great but not
the plan do we have to remind you
oh
if you're not gonna stick to the plan
maybe you shouldn't be the dipper to
dance with wendy if you think about it
five number five's on the point
we're gonna turn on each other i think
we all knew we were lying no no oh
no
no
i can't breathe in here yeah you can
plus there's snacks and a coloring book
in there for you
that plastic stick
watch it don't shove people
nothing freaks people
[Laughter]
what would you do if you were trapped in
a closet break out
haha if we start fighting it'll just go
on for infinity
it's true when you think about it
clone fight
get him
[Music]
oh
[Laughter]
yep
i don't know you want to go grab a
couple sodas or something
can he drink soda applaud to vote for
mabel
[Applause]
on your next contestant pacifica
[Applause]
this has like never happened before
we have a winner
is pacifica northwest
maybe we don't have as many friends as
pacifica but we have each other and that
is pretty good i think that's true some
night huh
you can't have soda man
yeah he's gonna dis disintegrate
[Music]
oh yeah remember what we talked about uh
of course
hey and quit being such a wimp around
wendy okay for my sake
well done show that was a great one i
enjoy that one a lot
enjoy that one a lot
uncomfortably nerve-wracking at the
right times hilarious
utilized it's
uh you know twilight zone concept very
well i've like planted the seed early
implemented it early enough on in the
show
watch it i i thought this was really
well executed from uh beginning to end
and also got to have some reflective
moments between the two dippers
this is good this is good i liked how he
like used it for like a social anxiety
uh moment in his life of that that thing
a lot of us can relate to of asking that
girl to dance with you i sucked at that
me sucked at that and i love yeah that
it's that asked you to dance
not in high school right i would go up
to you and be like you sexy man like
just grab yourself grab me on that on
the buns and then just yeah they grab
grab me lift me by my house and then
they would just like forklift me
i didn't even want to dance they're like
we are dancing yeah yeah and they just
hold on to my ass the whole night um
yeah this was really well executed in
every way yeah and i liked how it was
just so immediate in this one night
yeah i love that it's it's that it's not
that he's co-owning himself so that he
can like enslave himself to get stuff
done or something it's just he needs
advice from somebody who understands his
deepest anxieties and uh yeah the show
shows that it knows its character dipper
so well to the point that it's really
believable how this all escalated and
the way it went mm-hmm yeah and i really
liked the way they used that motif
because that was a genuine thing and i
was like i forgot about the copier until
it came back around and i was like oh
yeah like the idea light bulb hit me
around the time it hit him
and i like that when you have a setup
and you know what's coming but then you
can you know yeah be swept away into
just the other circumstances so that
when the actual you know hook comes back
yeah it's got a little bit of punch and
surprise and i thought the whole thing
with you know mabel and this party made
a nice like backdrop because for the
most part like this is pretty focused on
what dipper's doing and then you check
in with these bits that are the party
and i thought that worked nicely as a
device
like with the percolating
percolating
tension
knowing something's coming yeah this
real tone poem of silliness and uh party
vibes you know yeah for sure
rooting for him and wendy hope they get
together it's before the show gets
canceled at the end of season two yeah
that i just learned about
you know we're on a journey to just feel
incomplete this is our new snyder cup
that's what's up man
we can make up our own ending by the end
of it release gravity falls season three
restore the resources
yeah
um
and then yeah this uh this thing with
like mabel um finding a a crowd to hang
with some girls that she can be actual
friends with i hope they all come back
and i was like oh there's more to this
town yeah and seeing like the other
people here and getting a sense of that
like junior high vibe yeah yeah yeah and
it seems like pacifica could easily be
like a bully character who could come
back
and uh other things and uh yeah i i
really enjoyed this scene where he
actually winds up talking to wendy like
i think they make it a good sort of
question mark out of it because when
you're that age like three years
difference feels like a ton
so like they they draw this fun line
between
now i can't have she's older than him
but she's not that much older than him
so who knows you know yeah i like the
tension and the clock to it all yeah
yeah absolutely and just the bits you
know like like seuss i thought was
really funny throughout this even the
little things with grunkle stan like
that one just the timing on things like
that like when he's uh you know bribing
dipper with the tape he's got a
recording of him saying like i promised
and he's like shifting out of frame and
popping back in and
yeah i think uh i think what it is is um
you know with him learning that don't
overthink it
you have to map everything out just
learn to be yourself and be in the
moment with them and just converse have
some fun yeah
wrong charisma on command watch that
youtube channel people it'll show you
how to land the girl that's right
all the mathematical choices you should
make to guarantee that women will just
hop right into your lap yeah especially
if you're young if you're a teenager
happens to be watching this video
charisma on command what's the book to
get the pick up artist book oh oh yeah
the uh
the heart of the
deal how to win friends and influencers
uh
what is that pick-up part
yeah i used to know the name of it yeah
i never read it should have read it you
used to know the name for countless
punchlines
you know the art of
or i might just think of the pickup
artist it's not like the art of the
pickup or some like riff like that
pick up all of your part of the game or
something so that might be it yeah
but uh yeah guys uh this was a
seriously delightful episode and um
like it just keeps getting better yeah i
really was the last one that could be in
store one or the two episodes ago the
convenience store one i really really
really like the lock
i like that one a lot yeah something as
simple as this and like the way they
like bring the wonder and like oh the
that's what i like with the concept of
like oh there's benefits to this yeah
you know yeah there's joy to this and
then oh here's how i could really go
wrong i didn't like the realization of
like the paper one like that for some
reason that was like so disturbing to me
yeah like this like [ __ ] up copy okay
yeah it's perfect because it's also like
yeah just like one of the things that is
bound to happen with an actual
photocopier printer and yeah it's like
it goes to the place where you
ultimately expect any i cloned myself a
bunch of times thing to go which is yeah
they're all gonna fight and there might
be some confusion as to who's who but
yeah i love that it takes a while to get
there and they're all pretty much on the
same page up until a certain point and
it's not even so much about them all
getting greedy it's about the plan
and then when it all falls apart then
they start getting greedy yeah that's
true um but yeah even just establishing
the whole thing where they disintegrate
like right off the bat like i thought it
was interesting that they chose to do
that up front even because uh i feel
like certain other things might have you
know made that like the big reveal of
like oh here's the salvation but it's
always there so like i need rules that's
right that's right guys
what did you think about this episode
leave your thoughts down below
uh subscribe click that bell hit that
like button last but not least let's do
a peek
anisa oliva anisa my dear if there's
anyone at our patreon page who could use
a clone it would be you because you have
so much going on in your life you got
this big family at home that you have to
tend to then you have this crazy job
where you're always at risk of catching
the vidcon so it would be great you know
like because we love that you love to
help people and even want to visit here
if you could photocopy yourself to be a
nice set home multiple nieces at work to
help save more lives and then an anissa
that comes to california to meet john at
the lax gas station my god it would be
perfect and then we could get another
clone of you take you to eric horseman
in atlanta and also go see bradley
blisso and then you could also clone
yourself to go on a date with that
republican guy that you brought up a
year ago so anissa just the more of you
the better life would be there's no
denying that
ever
get that republican guy again get it if
you could make a copy of yourself
and then affect its political beliefs
that would be very impressive
[Music]